good to meet you thanks for having me i
saw your uh i saw your movie last night
at a
at a screening you know one of those
things where they arranged and so
usually those are real subdued
you know there's a bunch of industry
people and it's a real powerful film
people were
people were shouting like guys sitting
there in suits were like you know
shouting at each other this is a pretty
intense movie that's what you're
supposed to do it's supposed to
be one of those movies that stays with
you is it still with you yeah
i'm doing my job yeah i know it was uh
and the movie you know for people who
don't know anything about it
there's a movie about you're hoping a
typical campus right
well no not the typical campus it's a
it's
a campus that's kind of like a microcosm
for america itself
you know america is becoming you know
they say more conservative but it's
almost like more
fascists and that's what the you know
the picture
um is like yeah and this was like you
know a lot of the movie is it's not just
a black and white it's a lot of
different
kinds of people can't get along yeah
people are you know divided over over
their sex and
you know ethnicity everything you know
it's just one big
battleground yeah and it really it made
it made college
uh you know you see this it makes it a
very intense experience does this
reflect at all
what your experience was like i mean was
it was it that intense i think
my experience at uh i went to the
university of southern california usc
all right i reserve your applause but um
my experience was a little bit less
intense than than um
the characters in the picture but um it
was very intense
you know what i mean what kind of things
did you experience there you know
sometimes it's very easy for people to
think well you know racism that kind of
division
it's not as bad you know people have a
tendency to put that like in the 60s or
something did you no no i mean you know
at that school that school is a
predominantly white university
and um you know and it's it's set like
right um
near south central los angeles and but
it's like a big island
and um you know and i was like you know
i just well i could walk right off the
campus you know
it's like it was like going to school in
my neighborhoods i didn't have anything
really to worry about
but um i mean being on the campus um
you know and being you know
african-american and going on on that
campus it was it was kind of like
constricting for me
um in a lot of ways how did people react
because i know i i guess
you know you felt like some resistance
to you wanted to be a filmmaker well
you're in the film program i got in the
film program and um you know
and you know i was one of like 14
african americans in a program that had
like 2 000 students
and and you know since my success
they've admitted like you know
more than that but i mean you know when
i was there i mean kid
you know dudes used to like you know
look at me and be like uh well you know
you should just give it up you know
because you're black and you'll never
make it and
then you know you know we're gonna make
movies and you're gonna make movies and
it's just like
after a while i was like you know i was
trying to be cool with people but i was
like you know what
you know kill this you know so i just
stepped to everybody after that and i
was like listen
i'm gonna make movies you are not gonna
make movies you have nothing to talk
about
uh-huh i have life you know i have a
life you know what what are you going to
talk about you know what if you're here
i'm talking about growing up in encino
you know so i started becoming more one
alien could visit you know
i started i started becoming they put me
in a position where
where i had to be like i thought i had
to be big up on them you know i had to
be like
10 times better and i had to like you
know be as irratible as they were
because everybody there was trying to be
like george lucas or steven spielberg
everybody
they would grow beards they look like
spielberg and
look like lucas and they wear the right
kind of glasses and stuff
and i was like you know people will say
oh you're trying to be like special i
was trying to be like john singleton i
was trying to define my own
identity as as you know as a as a person
and maybe i'd find it if i got a chance
to make a movie now
do you call these people now get them on
the phone no
you should do that they call me they
call you jobs you know
so um yeah but it's all right you know
there's no
there's no uh there's no love lost yeah
well you grew up in uh
you grew up in south central and i
remember when i saw boys in the hood i
thought
uh this must be in some ways very
autobiographical i mean
you know lawrence fishburne's playing
your your dad in that manner yeah that
film was uh
um you know at the time i was saying it
wasn't autobiographical but there were a
lot of things in the film that
um you know were directly from my life
you know was your dad a strict guy like
that or was he yeah he was he was really
strict you know i grew up um
first with my mother and then i started
acting up and my mother's like
you know you're getting out of line you
got to go over to your daddy so um
you know i did that and i thought cool
you know i live with my pops
i'll be able to stay out to 10 o'clock
every night you know i was like
12 13. he was like uh nah it's not gonna
go like that
yeah you know he's like you're gonna
have to like you know wash dishes and do
our stuff it's like almost slave labor
you know he
he had all he had to do was work you
know 40 40 45 hours a week i had to
come home and wash dishes and everything
you know it just seemed so unfair at the
time but
you know now i know otherwise